he tubers is Charlie so Robert Danny jr.
was freaking people out this morning he
posted a picture of him at lunch with
the powers of the Marvel Universe a lot
of the spider-man Avengers people so
there's just a breakdown of what's going
on in the status of Iron Man 4 in the
Marvel Universe so what's going on here
this looks like a meeting of the Marvel
Illuminati everybody in their post was
saying stay tuned you know working on
something really cool so going around
the table from left to right you have
the Russo brothers Tom Holland who's
still working on spider-man they're
still shooting that right now you have
Jon Favreau who is also guest starring
in spider-man homecoming Robert Downey
jr. we knows in spider-man this person
here next to Robert Downey jr. is Roy
Choi he's kind of like a celebrity chef
Jon Favreau did a movie called chef that
was partially based on his life and he
was a producer on that then of course
you know the Godfather himself Kevin
Feige so Marvel looks like it's just
like shut down this restaurant for lunch
in Atlanta just having some sort of
crazy meeting where they planned the end
of the world so a lot of you will know
that Jon Favreau is a longtime director
of the Iron Man films he's kind of the
guy who gave Marvel their big shot as a
studio when they were getting ready for
the first Iron Man movie it was a huge
risk they had a problem insuring Robert
Downey jr. like it took a while because
he was coming through a period in his
career where he was still kind of
cleaning up his image and Marvel wasn't
distributing its own films at the time
so they were still working with
Paramount so this was during like the
Marvel paramount era before Disney
bought them out around the first
Avengers film but this was all before
Marvel had blown up nobody had seen Iron
Man they didn't know was going to be
amazing they're like oh my god this is
what a superhero movie can be so Jon
Favreau very important to the Marvel
Universe but after Iron Man 2 just kind
of decided to go off and make different
films he just did the jungle book which
did gangbusters at the box office so Jon
Favreau still a very good very popular
director very much in demand Marvel has
been trying to get him back to work on
another project he said that he would
totally come back to do another Iron Man
film eventually but Robert Downey jr. as
of like the last Iron Man film you know
when they were working on Avengers age
of Ultron like even a while ago before
Civil War
to happen was kind of iffy on whether or
not he was going to do another film this
is turning into like a Marvel behind the
blow documentary so there was a lot of
drama going on behind the scenes with
the people like the executives up at the
top that Kevin Feige was having to work
with in making all these Marvel films
they're just like a lot of things they
didn't have anything to do with the
movies that were making things difficult
for them to do the things they wanted to
do so recently you all know that Disney
like basically alan horne up at the top
at disney who's Kevin Feige is boss said
okay Marvel Studios you can go off do
your movies and be like your own
separate division you don't have to
report to anyone but me nobody's going
to nickel-and-dime you anymore you don't
have to worry about that kind of stuff
so they were able to kind of rework
their relationships with all the actors
in everyone who was like you know what
maybe I'm not gonna be Captain America
anymore maybe I'm not going to be iearnt
anymore we're rethinking their strategy
like okay yeah I could totally come back
for more movies so really the big holdup
with a new Iron Man film is them just
selling Robert Downey jr. on a good idea
like he's just waiting like he doesn't
need to make another film like he can do
whatever he wants he has more money than
Jesus now so he's really just waiting
for the right story to come along so as
with all things that Marvel even though
they have like a list of movies that
they're working on right now there's
like a warehouse of people just mining
ideas trying to turn things into scripts
for ideas that might become movies down
the road there is an army of people
pitching new ideas to Kevin Feige all
the time so that when he finds one that
he likes he brings it to Robert Downey
jr. and they say hey why don't we turn
this into a movie but really the bigger
change I think that's going to get
Robert Downey jr. more excited about
doing a new Iron Man story in the
direction it might take is his
relationship with spider-man now like
what has changed in the Marvel Universe
in a big way we have spider-man we have
like a high-school franchise select the
Russos when they were talking about how
they sold Robert Downey jr. on coming
into civil war they pitched him the idea
of a guilt-ridden Tony Stark someone who
was dealing with all this terrible stuff
that had happened after sokovia so you
can see when they're pitching Robert
Downey jr. ideas for new movies they
always start with Tony Stark's emotional
art so when you're thinking about what
they might do
Iron Man 4 think about where the Tony
Stark character would logically go like
what would he be doing well it'd still
feel a little guilty about the way
things went down in Civil War and would
probably want to make things right and
what would be better than helping a
brilliant kid reach his full potential
as a human being and as a superhero so
if you like pending developments in
spider-man homecoming Tony Stark is
unofficially emotionally adopted Peter
Parker you can write whatever fan
fiction you want to about the two of
them but spider-man Iron Man have a
long-standing relationship in the comics
it just makes sense that they would
slowly move closer to that in the movies
- so here's the pitch for the next Iron
Man movie and they wouldn't be able to
do it for a little while but I think
it'd be good so after infinity war after
spider-man homecoming they're like
there's so much crossover between the
spider-man universe which is a huge
universe of characters in Marvel's
existing one right now is they do a
version of world's most wanted wherein
Norman Osborn seizes control of shield
in the wake of what happens during Civil
War Secret Invasion Dark Avengers like
the government gets really heavy-handed
in the Avengers he makes a play for Tony
Stark who goes on the run so it's
basically Tony Stark versus Norman
Osborn is the iron patriot but I think
it'd be better if you weren't iron
patriot
so that's bit more of like a Spider Man
Iron Man crossover movie or if you want
it to go like the really big Civil War
route you know like Civil War was a
Captain America movie but it was kind of
like a backdoor Avengers film you could
also like the other really awesome thing
that I would like to see them - would be
all-new all-different Avengers so in the
Avengers right now Tony Stark's company
isn't doing really great there are three
different Avengers teams but the one
that Tony is working with is the one
with Miles Morales Kamala Khan is
basically like all these new characters
the female Thor he's kind of like the
father figure to all these young
Avengers
so it would be more in the vein of the
high school John Hughes spider-man
homecoming movie in a traditional Iron
Man film because there's one of two ways
that you can go with an Iron Man movie
like this you know because it's the
fourth movie you can go really big so
you could do like all-new all-different
Avengers or - you could go way smaller
like in the way Iron Man 3 was a much
smaller film than iron
two fewer characters tighter narrative
it would be more of like a psychological
journey that Tony would go on so a lot
of this will depend on how he gets used
exact like what his scenes are like in
spider-man homecoming but we kind of
have an idea for what his relationship
is with the spider-man character so you
can guess that what he's going to be
doing and I feel like Robert Downey jr.
also probably enjoys not having to hold
a film up by himself so what I think
I'll probably end up happening is is
that instead of doing a solo Iron Man
movie they'll do like a civil war type
crossover it's more focused on Iron
Man's character but also revolves around
a whole bunch of other new characters
like Captain Marvel's spider-man like
all the new people that you would try to
usher into the Avengers but let me know
in the comments what do you want them to
do for the next Iron Man film big
crossover like Civil War or like a
really small film like Iron Man 3 but
keep in mind there are so many films
that they have on the schedule already
that they're working on so if they did
do another Iron Man movie it probably
wouldn't happen until phase 4 till after
like the second infinity war movie so
know like a lot of people saw this in
the like hey is Jon Favreau gonna do one
of the Avengers movies no the Russos are
still directing both of the next
Avengers films and they're also writing
it that's not changing none of this is
changing it's just this pictures being
taken in Atlanta in Marvel's filming two
films right now in Atlanta concurrently
including spider-man and Avengers
infinity war in five of the people
sitting at this table are starring in or
actively shooting the films so there's
just like a whole lot of Marvel stuff
happening so it makes sense that if
they're going to have like a lunch and
talk about big stuff that they would
invite the really big people associated
with those films so just a heads up that
the Captain America Civil War blu-ray is
still going on all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so what's going
to happen next is there's been a whole
bunch of Luke Cage Punisher Season one
Wolverine like they just announced that
the villain of Wolverine 3 is going to
be mr. sinister so big freakin deal so
I'm going to do all those videos as fast
as possible next video will be up
Tuesday morning so get hyped there's
gonna be so much awesome stuff happening
in the next couple of weeks well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here to watch the new Ghost Rider
trailer and you can click here for the
Supergirl season 2 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys